zum achtelfinale in die hülle des virus
das weiterkommen gegen ungarn könnten
teuer erkauft seien für fußball
deutschland am dienstag in wembley gegen
eine ganz neue angriffs variante namens
delta da würden dann auch die
abwehrkünste der deutschen spieler
endgültig versagen 60.000 fans sollen
dabei sein wo die ferien die stehen
ebenfalls vor der türe und viele wollen
reißen alles nur schwarz malerei delta
fußball urlaub was bringt der korona
sommer jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet ist andreas gassen
der vorstandsvorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung aus
london mein kollege jahr sind herrlein
zdf korrespondent für das vereinigte
königreich und irland
hier im studio sitzt die
wissenschaftsjournalistin christina
satori und professor henning vöpel ist
der direktor des hamburgischen
weltwirtschaftsinstituts vergaßen sie
sind ja wenn ich das richtig gelesen
habe er ein fan von lockerungen von
freiheit auch von mehr
eigenverantwortung erwarten sie denn
einen unbeschwerten corona sommer der
sommer hat durchaus das potenzial
relativ unbeschwert zu sein und sie
haben richtig gesagt ich bin durchaus
den fan von eigenverantwortung und mit
vernünftiger herangehensweise kann man
sicherlich auch relativ viel schon
machen ohne ein gewisses die kurze
laufen sich mit cola
ob jetzt ein fußball endspiel mit 60.000
menschen dann gleich eine geniale start
ist das wird man dann sehen hinterher
aber einen normalen urlaub steht
sicherlich relativ wenig im wege
story wie können wir denn dem der
sogenannten delta variante dieser neuen
gefährlichen mutation des virus ein
schnippchen schlagen und ich glaube es
ist wie damals als diese erste variante
dass alf die alpha variante aufgetreten
ist man sieht dass es eine variante ist
die sich noch besser verbreiten kann das
heißt man muss sich noch besser an die
maßnahmen halten es sind die gleichen
maßnahmen abstand halten maske tragen
vorsichtig sein
vielleicht sich vorher testen bevor man
jemanden trifft man muss es nur noch
strikter machen vielleicht jetzt nicht
weil die inzidenz niedrig ist aber bald
um diesem dieser variante geringere
chancen zu geben
herr lang die delta variante die spricht
im moment noch hauptsächlich englisch
wie reagiert denn die insel auf diese
variante unsicher panisch oder gelassen
erst mal mit unsicherheit also von panik
ist hier noch keine rede aber aber
unsicherheit hat das natürlich schon
ausgelöst man muss bedenken dass die
briten ja eigentlich vor ein paar tagen
den tag der großen freiheit hätten haben
sollen also ein tag an dem alle
restriktionen fallen das ist eben nicht
eingetreten und der grund dafür ist die
data variante jetzt ist das ganze vier
wochen verschoben worden auf den 19
juli und insofern fragen sich natürlich
die briten moment mal wo geht das jetzt
sind vögel delta ante portas hat die
wirtschaft schon den nächsten lockdown
im kopf so gewissermaßen als
urlaubssouvenir für den herbst hat sie
mich also moment ist alles auf puma
eingerichtet also alle haben enorm
positive erwartungen gehen davon aus
dass es keine erneuten lockdown gibt das
ist natürlich in gewisser weise auch
gefährlich weil wir ja wieder dazu
neigen die exponential i tät zu
unterschätzen ist also die saisonalität
des sommers hilft uns auch das impfen
natürlich aber es wäre glaube ich gut
sich an den herbst 2020 zu erinnern und
zu sehen dass dieser kampf noch nicht
gewonnen ist kann noch mal zurück jetzt
zwar einigen sich ja zwei wichtige mega
ereignisse in dieser woche auf sehr
ungute weise das ist die
europameisterschaft im fußball und eben
das auftreten das verstärkte auftreten
des delta der delta variante herr land
die eu die könnte daher als super
sprayer jetzt einstellung die
europäische noch mal die
europameisterschaft die em könnte da ja
als super später auftreten
in den nächsten wochen wie sehen denn
eigentlich die dritten die finalspiele
im eigenen land da ist ja nicht nur das
spiel gegen deutschland am dienstag bei
der halbfinals und auch das finale am 11
juli finden ja in london statt wie
reagieren die menschen und auch die
britischen medien auf dieses ereignis
nur positiv
naja mit gemischten gefühlen würde ich
mal sagen und es ist ja auch wirklich
eine zwickmühle auf der einen seite hat
man da diese sehr hohen incidents werte
jetzt hier sieben tage instituts auf 117
das ist die höchste wohl in europa wenn
ich mich nicht irre und das wird
natürlich merkwürdig ausgerechnet in
dieser situation solche spiele
auszutragen jetzt die achtelfinals vor
45.000 zuschauern und dann die
halbfinale und die und das finale vor
60.000 zuschauern also zwei drittel
auslastung des stadions auf der anderen
seite will die regierung natürlich nicht
dieses fußballfest den leuten wegnehmen
es ist richtig eine richtige zwickmühle
in der sie da stecken da kommen auch
viele andere faktoren noch dazu die uefa
offiziellen und sponsoren
die sollen ins land kommen dürfen ohne
quarantäne absitzen zu müssen das muss
man natürlich auch mal den briten
erklären die moment nicht nach spanien
oder nach frankreich oder nach italien
den urlaub fahren können weil sie bei
der rückkehr dann in quarantäne müssten
es ist nicht sehr schwierige abwägung
und die regierung greift dazu trick 17
greift in die trickkiste und hat jetzt
diese diese spiele zu testspielen also
testevent erklärt indem man sagt also
wir probieren das jetzt mal aus wie das
so funktioniert wenn wir jetzt weiter
lockern und solche veranstaltungen
durchführen und das ist ja so dass die
leute getestet sein müssen und sie
müssen oder oder geimpft sein müssen
also du kommst nicht rein ins stadion
ohne diese beiden kriterien erfüllen das
heißt diese massiv ansteigenden intent
sind jetzt in großbritannien wegen der
delta variante da kommt niemand auf die
idee möglicherweise die spielorte an die
usa zurück zu geben und zu sagen also
das ist uns jetzt zu gefährlich zu
gefährlich für das land selbst aber auch
zu gefährlich für die anreisenden
mannschaften fans und betreuer
ich glaube das letzte wort ist noch
nicht gesprochen
die diskussion ist die ganze zeit im
schwange ich habe aber nicht das gefühl
dass die briten selbst diesen schritt
jetzt gehen würden
da glaube ich müsste dann schon von
außen etwas kommen also das jetzt
wirklich die uefa sagt lasst uns das
ganze nach rom verlegen
zum beispiel aber die briten würden
jetzt nicht sagen da habe ich zumindest
nicht das gefühl dass ich das andeutet
uns ist das jetzt alles zu viel wir
geben das jetzt ab
jetzt haben wir ja gerade gehört auch
die zahlen steigen die delta variante
ist dominierend noch auf der insel aber
wahrscheinlich auch bald bei uns wie
gefährlich ist denn diese fußball
europameisterschaft als eine
paneuropäische meisterschaft von glasgow
über sevilla bis nach baku in
aserbaidschan also über den ganzen
kontinent gezogen für eine erfolgreiche
bekämpfung von corona wenn man auch sich
die benutzung von masken in stadien die
abstände in stadien an sind und die
frage ob auch immer sich alle an die
quarantäne halten was jetzt gerade sich
da in großbritannien entwickelt wie
gefährlich ist das für die korona
bekämpfung
ich glaube das kann man sehr schwer
abschätzen
ich glaube man darf es aber auch nicht
umgekehrt gleich wieder ein paar nichts
warnt es ist ja nicht so dass wir wurde
eine komplette abschaffung der
europäischen länder untereinander gehört
das gab zumindest der kurze zeit um der
sinn und zweck der nachgang beurteilt
worden
ob das jetzt wirklich relevante
ausbildungs bei ihnen und macht hat weiß
man nicht ich glaube entscheidend ist
und es ist schon eine völlig andere
situation als vor einem jahr
da hatten wir zwar auch sinken der
inzidenz und dinge durch eine
saisonalität des virus corona wir sind
halt saisonal aber wir haben natürlich
jetzt eine weiten umhängen greifende
impfung die könnte noch viel weiter sein
mit dem im shop wetten
aber wir haben eine bevölkerung die
zunehmend durch impfen ist und wir
wissen aus aktuellen untersuchen
zumindest die data und wohl auch die
schon nächste anstehende varianten die
kappe variante menschen mit zwei
impfungen also einen vollständigen
impfschutz sind auch gegen diese
varianten insofern geschützt dass sie
keinen schweren verlauf erleiden und
deshalb muss man auch das thema inzidenz
etwas kritischer betrachten immer schon
betont inzidenz ist einer von vielen
werten die der betrachtung bedürfen aber
viel entscheidender ist ja nicht nur wie
viele menschen infizieren sich sondern
wie
oder erkannten sie überhaupt und dass
sich ein virus verändert ist eigentlich
die norm und nicht die ausnahme
aus sicht eines virus ist es ja schlau
anstecken dazu werden die varianten
scheinen immer weiter investitions tag
nach oben zu wandern also immer weiter
zur nase hin die symptomatik setzt auch
ob die wirklich gefährlicher sind da
gibt es bisher keinen hinweis und ich
glaube es tatsächlich wenn wir durch
eine hohe durchimpfungsrate haben können
das ganze viel von seinem schrecken
verlieren deshalb muss man die
gleichzeitig werden aber die situation
ist schon eine grundlegend andere als
vor einem jahr
warum ist schlau ist 60.000 leute ohne
masken starken ist eine ganz andere das
ist doch ganz kurz hatte beim fußball
bleiben was man da gezielt aber nicht
nur das verhalten der eu schon wieder
europäische union gesagt meine herren
die uefa in diesem fall also die den
europäischen fußballverband das
verhalten der uefa aber auch das war
schon im stadion sieht eben das färbt ja
auch viele zuschauer hatten das gucken
millionen diese spiele an
ist das ein gutes zeichen nach außen wie
wir im moment mit diesem thema umgehen
ich persönlich will das höchst
frustrierend also zu sehen dass die
kinder bis jetzt vor kurzem bis die
ferien angefangen haben masken tragen
mussten jeden tag sich zwei drei mal die
woche testen lassen mussten damit sie
endlich wieder gemeinsam mit ihren
freunden in die schule gehen können
und dann entsteht plötzlich werden da
ohne not 60.000 leute in ein stadion
gelassen man sieht dass maximal die
masken am arm getragen werden wo ich
denke das kann nicht sein
wie kann man so sorglos sein und auf der
anderen seite gerade den jungen menschen
die so viel durchgemacht haben dieser
pandemie die sowie zurück gesteckt haben
und die arbeit immer extrem darauf
geachtet dass sie getestet werden und
dass sie die masken tragen was ja auch
richtig ist aber jetzt plötzlich tut man
so als wenn schon alles vorbei wäre und
es stimmt wir sind in der anderen
situation aber wir sind ja noch nicht
durch und mit dem testen muss man sagen
es gibt noch viele menschen über 60 die
noch nicht ihre zweite impfung haben und
gerade bei delta sieht man erst ab der
zweiten impfung hat man einen wirklich
guten schutz kommt er wenn die gegenrede
werde jetzt wahrscheinlich lauten
unterschied zum letzten jahr auch wir
sind jetzt relativ die durch im punkt
kommt ja jetzt die impfquote wird immer
höher
dann ist das nicht mehr so gravierend
wie wir das in den vergangenen monaten
erlebt habe
im herbst wird es so sein ja noch ist es
nicht so noch gibt es wie gesagt viele
menschen die über 60 sind noch nicht die
zweite impfung haben beziehungsweise die
auch vielleicht unter 60 sind aber sagen
wir mal stark übergewichtig sind oder
rauchen oder irgendwelche anderen
risikofaktoren haben auch die sind immer
noch gefährdet und dann muss man im
herbst auch gucken
man sieht dass gerade bei den sehr viel
älteren menschen auch der impfschutz
nicht hundertprozentig ist das heißt wer
ein oder andere kann sich doch immer
noch damit anstecken und die kinder die
kinder und jugendlichen sind dann
wahrscheinlich zum großen teil noch
nicht geimpft weil auch noch nicht ganz
klar ist aber dennoch dass nutzen
verhältnis ist und ich glaube was keiner
bildung was deutschland wirklich nicht
verantworten kann ist das noch mal so
ein schuljahr und so ein universitäts
jahr abläuft das ist die nächste
generation und die muss jetzt wieder
ihre bildung bekommen damit sie unseren
segen bekommen wir im lauf der sendung
noch einmal zurückkehrt
die ökonomischen folgen können ja auch
gewaltig sein da könnt ihr schon mal
wieder bei der em bei der
europameisterschaft anfangen da wird
wahrscheinlich die sponsoren auf die
palme gehen wenn oder auf die barrikaden
gehen wenn jetzt spielbaren änderungen
stattfinden würden aber auch wenn man
das jetzt so weiterlaufen lässt könnten
ja im falle einer starken starken
anstiegs dieser sogenannten delta
variante unter den crooner infizierten
enorme neue enorme ökonomische schäden
entstehen
absolut also ein rückfall in den walk
down wäre wäre nicht gut weil wie gesagt
alles ist auf expansion ausgerichtet
nicht also wir haben eine enorme
boomphase und und sozusagen die
enttäuschung das ist jetzt doch zurück
in die lockdown führt wäre wäre groß das
ist gar keine frage umgekehrt glaube ich
um später noch mal auf die em
zurückzukommen glaube ich ist es auch
schön für uns dass wir natürlich
umgekehrt sehen wir sind europa nicht
also wir sind nicht alleine damit
sondern anderen geht es auch so ich will
dass du gar nicht gar nicht kleinreden
die bilder sind sind übertrieben das ist
auch nicht gut dass der stattfindet aber
wir brauchen ja auch im mentalen umgang
damit und allein gestern waren natürlich
irgendwie es gemeinsame emotionale
erlebnis ist natürlich toll dass das
hilft uns ja auch
irgendwie zu sehen dass das leben sich
ausdehnen dass das virus aber sozusagen
natürlich das leben wieder zurückdrängt
und das ist immer der das gleiche spiel
so deshalb fand ich die eben jetzt nicht
negativ sondern es hat eben auch auf
positive signale gesendet was man isst
hat den insgesamt bei der wirtschaft
also im handel dienstleistungen
industrie da irgendwie mehr sensibilität
eingesetzt gegenüber dem letzten jahr da
hat man sich ja zum teil massive die
politik geärgert über locker und über
einschränkungen über beschränkungen auch
dass es natürlich erhebliche
auswirkungen auf die
unternehmensergebnisse auch auf die
gewinne hatte dass man damals eben
dagegen die politik richtig vorgegangen
ist hat man jetzt vielleicht eher eine
bewusstseinsveränderung da erlebt zu
sagen
es nützt uns wenig wenn wir zu früh
lockern wenn wir wieder in die vollen
gehen sonst diesen rückfall in london
wieder und dann ist der wirtschaftliche
schaden noch größer
das hat man glaube ich in der tat ganz
gut verstanden dass das kein dilemma ist
oder dass man sozusagen das eine mich
gegen das andere ausspielen darf sondern
gesundheitsschutz ist im grunde auch im
kern schutz der wirtschaft also das ist
kein gegensatz
das hat man glaube ich gut verstanden
ich kann aber umgekehrt viele stimmen
aus der wirtschaft verstehen die sagen
also wir brauchen auch eine strategie
darauf ist nicht also immer nur
zurückzufahren abzuwarten war vielleicht
am anfang auch rhetorisch von der
politik gefährlich zu sagen
die erwartungshaltung zu suggerieren wir
müssen nur lange genug abwarten und dann
können wir aus also vielleicht wäre die
ansage wir müssen irgendwann damit leben
wir müssen sozusagen irgendwie gucken
wir mit dem risiko umgehen wäre glaube
ich klüger gewesen weil es auch mental
sozusagen und sind andere andere haltung
gebracht hätte und ich glaube das zu
recht auch die kritik besteht dass wir
in vielen gesellschaftlichen bereichen
einfach keine kreativen konzept da wäre
dann sozusagen ein kurzer und knackiger
lockdown im herbst oder kurz nach
weihnachten besser gewesen da gab es ja
auch massive widerstände die politik ist
ein bisschen eingeknickt und hat dadurch
ja eigentlich das dilemma verlängert
absolut ja also exponentielle dynamik
heißt die beste chance das einzudämmen
hat man ganz nah an
und indem man ganz strikt dass das wird
man schauen es sozusagen das feuer
auszutreten
und das muss man auch jetzt wieder in
erwägung ziehen
also man darf ja jetzt nicht wieder rein
laufen sondern diese pandemie besteht
auch darin zu antizipieren was ist der
zweite und dritte schritt man hat in der
politik immer gesagt ja wir machen wir
das was als nächstes sinnvoll ist aber
muss natürlich auch eine idee davon
entwickeln was danach kommt ich habe
gerade gesagt wovon sie sehen jetzt sage
ich mal wovon sie wahrscheinlich nicht
fans sind nämlich von noka weht also
diesen runterfahren diesen lockdown wenn
im herbst eine ähnliche situation
passieren würde wegen delta wie im
vergangenen jahr wäre es dann doch
sinnvoller so ganz kurz und hatten
lockdown zu machen als erfahrung aus dem
vergangenen jahr
also ich würde mal die prognose wagen
wir werden keine situation bekommen wie
im letzten jahr
und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
dass politik dass die karte noch mal
spielt weil das wird man wirklich jetzt
überstrapaziert und der erfolg war
relativ nah wir haben begonnen mit dem
bogdan erster november und das ist dann
irgendwo ganz stieg um aus getrödelt
jetzt im prinzip fast erst im juni und
die zahlen gingen runter das lässt sich
sehr leicht überprüfen eigentlich mit
dem einsetzen der impfkampagne in
größerem umfang also lockten ist ist ein
thema was wänden überhaupt und das habe
ich letztes jahr schon gesagt werden
überhaupt da muss man tatsächlich seien
14 tage um alles ich das ist eher
unrealistisch und wir sehen alle diese
serie cupid apostel werden eigentlich
immer wieder eines besseren belehrt das
lässt nicht damit weg bringen das
manchmal zwei wochen alle geschäfte
wir haben brocken ausgerottet als
einziges meiner kenntnis nach das ist
eine jahrzehnte lange impfkampagne
geschehen aber man muss natürlich
schauen dass man dass man instrumente im
köcher hat und das ist vollkommen
richtig was gerade gesagt wurde
wir müssen einfach optionen entwickeln
wie gehen wir mit höheren instanzen um
wie weit können wir in der zeit
sicherstellen dass das unser system
nicht überlastet haben wir vernünftige
datenbasen die hatten wir bisher nicht
die haben immer noch nicht und insofern
ist das eigentlich ein ziemlich
trauriges schauspiel wenn man sich
anschaut dass corinna vor gut anderthalb
jahren begonnen hat dass man eigentlich
diese offenkundigen dinge nicht getan
hat wenn ich jetzt wäre das vor einigen
wochen erst belüftungs werte für schulen
frei
geben wollen sind ist das ehrlicherweise
insofern glaube ich mein block dann wird
es nicht mehr geben wir werden an der
innsbrucker arbeiten müssen und werden
dann schauen wie man höhere instanzen
beherrscht kontrolliert
entscheidend ist dass wir keine so hohen
krankheitszahlen bekommen da bin ich
eben bei einer hohen quote dort deutlich
zu viel komik apostel hat sie sich
angesprochen gefühlt das nicht unbedingt
wobei man sieht ja jetzt wie schön es
ist wenn die institute niedrig ist wie
viel freiheit ein mögliches von daher
denke ich was die apostel nennen das
sind die die er letztendlich recht
behalten haben
ich möchte den wir auch widersprechen
dass der doktor nichts gebracht hat also
wir haben auch gesehen als er das erste
mal im frühling am anfang des jahres als
die politik eingeknickt ist wie sie
gesagt haben und kein locker und gemacht
hat sondern nur diesen diesen lockdown
leid da ist nichts passiert und auf den
intensivstationen sah es wirklich nicht
gut aus und die sind erst runter
gegangen die zahlen als dann ein harter
lockdown gemacht wurde
also dieses argument die zahl sind
runter gegangen weil dann der
sommeranfang der markt eine rolle
gespielt haben aber das ist doch so als
wenn ich auto fahre ich bevor ich in
eine kurve fahren und dann komme ich gut
durch die kurve und dann sage ich
rückblickend auch dann natürlich auch
mit 100 kilometer in der stunde
durchfahren können ist auch nichts
passiert
ohne den lock und ich verstehe es auch
nicht alle anderen länder die ein
problem hatten mit kuwait 19 mit corona
sind nur durch einen lock down auf
niedrige zahlen gekommen warum glauben
wir deutschen das video nicht nötig
haben ich glaube auch das wird im herbst
was anderes weil viele alte menschen
geimpft sind und dadurch die
krankheitslast eine andere ist ganz klar
wir werden corona die nächsten jahre
haben und wir sind stehen aber besser da
weil wir geimpft sind und dann können
wir mit dem virus leben aber es immerzu
dieses wir müssen mit dem virus leben zu
lernen zu leben lernen
das geht erst wenn wir alle geimpft sind
weil ohne immunität können wir mit dem
ding nicht leben
es gibt ja nun hinlänglich studie nehmen
sie die auf israel da hat man sehr schön
nachweisen können wie der lockerer
gewirkt haben wenige impfung
kann man da ist völlig klar dass die
impfung den unterschied machen auch die
uni münchen hat jetzt das würde noch mal
gearbeitet also der lok dann nur wenn
man ihn überall macht ist er nicht gut
ist wird auch weltweit werden fossile
brennstoffe verbrannt das ist auch nicht
gut machen trotzdem alle also man muss
halt auch ein bisschen rational rangehen
und wir haben auch die sind ja weit von
zero entfernt
es ist doch absurd zu meinen wir hätten
jetzt werden sie roh cupid ähnliche
situation immer auch eine dunkelziffer
haben wir haben auch immer noch das geht
ja nicht weg aber die kosten wird
sie können sie den trennen das klavier
gleichzeitig ein blogger und gemacht
wird und es geht los mit dem impfen
wieso sagen sie dann es liegt nur an dem
impfen also gerade weil man sieht dass
in den ländern wie england wie israel
und auch in deutschland das zusammenfiel
der lock down und auch in frankreich zum
beispiel und und auch in portugal erst
durch den locker und sind auch die zahl
und das ist doch auch gar nicht schlimm
das ist das was alle wissenschaftler
übrigens in studien sagen es ist eine
ganze scheibe es reicht nicht eine eine
maßnahme es muss verschiedene greifen
das ist die impfung und das sind auch
die maßnahmen und wir wollen wir alle
hoffen dass im herbst diese diskussion
nicht noch mal nötig ist weil uns das
alles erspart bleibt das hängt ja auch
viel mit der impfquote zusammen
herr land man soll also die impfquote
weder überbewerten noch gering schätzen
in großbritannien spielt das eine große
rolle sie haben vorhin schon kurz
erwähnen der sogenannte freedom day der
ist jetzt um vier wochen verschoben
worden auf den 19
juli dann sollen alle beschränkungen
fallen das hat der premier boris johnson
den briten versprochen
ja ist das eine ein realistischer weg
ist das gar nicht der königsweg jetzt
für das land über sozusagen die korona
beklemmungen auch zu überwinden was mein
7 das mit versprechen
etwas so etwas versprechen es natürlich
so eine sache und ich meine die
regierung hier hat auch schon öfters
dinge in der kroner krise in der korona
phase viele dinge versprochen die sie
dann auch nicht halten konnte also muss
man vorsichtig sein
das zeigt ja auch die verschiebung um
vier wochen zeigte auch dieser freedom
day konnte nicht eingehalten werden
obwohl man zugegebenermaßen ein bisschen
vorsichtiger waren sagt also schauen uns
jeweils immer nach jeder stufe dann die
situation an um dann zu entscheiden ob
wir die nächsten den nächsten schritt
der lockerung auch tatsächlich
durchführen
aber vielleicht im zusammenhang mit der
diskussion die eben recht heftig geführt
wurde vielleicht einfach noch mal der
hinweis darauf dass man jetzt natürlich
auf dem kontinent oder sagen wir in
deutschland einen vorteil hat dass man
auf england schauen kann man kann hier
ja hinschauen und sehen wie entwickelt
sich die delta variante und die delta
variante
das sehen wir auch großbritannien hat
diese wirklich sehr ruhe durch impfung
ähnlich wie israel also hat das wirklich
ja das ist nach wie vor der fall dass
das wirklich sehr gut ist auch wenn im
kommt auf dem kontinent jetzt ja
aufgeholt wird aber trotzdem steigen die
infektionszahlen also es waren 16.000
neuinfektionen gestern und das spielt
sich dann bei personen die noch nicht
geimpft sind also wir haben noch hier
bei den 18 bis 25 jahren also bei den
sehr jungen haben wir haben wir noch
einen geringen anteil an doppelt
geimpften und und dort bei den jungen
haben wir auch die meisten fälle
und da muss man jetzt einfach drauf
schauen
das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich wie bei
der alpha variante oder die damals die
kennt variante hieß da war es ja auch so
da ist kam auskennt kam aus england und
man konnte eigentlich in deutschland und
auf dem kontinent drauf schauen was
stutzig denn jetzt eigentlich in england
und entsprechende lehren ziehen ich bin
mir nicht ganz sicher ob man damals die
richtigen lehren gezogen habe ich kann
mir nur wünschen dass man diesmal das
tut
die briten sind ja legendär haben einen
legendären ruf für ihren urlaub im
europäischen ausland was muss man sich
denn da eigentlich am 19 juli dann
vorstellen werden diese beschränkungen
tatsächlich auf
werden dein auto wettrennen zu den
flughäfen heathrow gatwick und luton
mehrerer flughäfen fallen jetzt gerade
nicht ein und im ganzen land natürlich
auch dazu dass dann sich sozusagen eine
britische urlauber auf die europäischen
urlaubszielen ergießt und trifft dort ja
auch viele andere mit europäer
das wird wahrscheinlich nicht der fall
sein denn diese aufhebung der
beschränkungen die gilt nicht zwingend
fürs reisen die gilt für beschränkungen
innerhalb des landes also für
großveranstaltungen für beerdigungen
hochzeiten für den umgang miteinander
dass man nicht mehr nur im beschränkten
gruppen sich jetzt zu sechst also innen
aufhalten kann
diese dinge werden aufgehoben aber das
reisen noch nicht da ist der unterschied
mit dem reisen ist die britische
regierung momentan noch wirklich sehr
sehr vorsichtig das heißt wenn man man
muss wenn man verreisen will das hatte
ich vorhin schon angedeutet wenn man
verreisen will auf den kontinent dann
muss man bei rückkehr in quarantäne zehn
tage oder man kann sich nach fünf tagen
frei testen lassen aber immerhin fünf
tage quarantäne und das ist teuer
es gibt zwar überlegungen das jetzt
richtung sommer etwas aufzulockern sehr
gerne und viel und die europäischen
länder portugal spanien hätten auch
gerne die kundschaft aber jetzt sitzt
der brite da kam die ganze zeit erzählt
wie toll er das gemacht hat mit dem
impfprogramm und jetzt muss er zusehen
wie die deutschen und die dänen und die
schwedin munter am mittelmeer
herumreisen und der engländer guckt in
die röhre und muss ins komplett
überfüllte cornwell oder devon gehen ja
wo man am strand kein parkplatz mehr
kriegt und abends auch keinen tisch mehr
in dem restaurant die regierungen
johnson hat so einiges überstanden in
dieser krise obwohl sie sich wirklich
viele fehler erlaubt hat aber das könnte
ihm zum verhängnis werden
und jetzt gibt es gar nicht wenn du das
haben wir jetzt gelernt nicht so viel
friede wie wir immer gedacht haben mit
dem 19
juli dem freedom day das ist vielleicht
jetzt hier in kontinentaleuropa auch ein
bisschen anders also viele wollen in
urlaub fahren
nur wie soll man sich das eigentlich
vorstellt ist das so sinnvoll die leute
auch zu ermuntern wegzufahren masken
pflicht abstand halten das gilt nicht
nur für fußballstadien
das ist auch am strand er misslich ich
denke ja am strand wenn man draußen ist
und man bleibt unter in seinem in seinem
haushalt oder in seiner gruppe dann ist
das ja auch nicht so gefährlich
das problem ist eher dass man schon
gesehen hat letztes jahr wenn man im
urlaub ist verhält man sich auch anders
ich mal nicht jeder feiert dann viel und
betrinkt sich viel und vergisst dann
einfach mal mit dem zweiten glas wein
vergisst man einfach auch bestimmte
regeln nicht jeder macht das aber einige
leute machen das und besonders gerne im
urlaub und wenn man dann im flieger
sitzt man kann nur hoffen dass es dieses
jahr ein bisschen besser wird weil
einfach mehr leute schon doppelt geimpft
sind und weil auch hoffentlich weiterhin
strenger kontrolliert wird zumindest bei
den flügen und dann getestet wird ich
denke es wäre sinnvoll
vor dem abflug und dann nochmal danach
zu testen weil der test ist eben eine
momentaufnahme
ich glaube wir kommen auch gar nicht
herum diese data variante man sieht
jetzt die verdoppelt sich auch in
deutschland die werden die im herbst
hier haben und dann müssen wir noch mal
alle vorsichtig sein weil keiner will
ich finde das ist ein großes anliegen
dass deutschland haben sollte dass dann
die variante durch die kinder und
jugendlichen rast und keiner will dass
kitas und schulen und universitäten
geschlossen bleiben im herz herbst das
können wir uns nicht leisten als
deutschland das ist die generation die
all unsere fehler wieder gutmachen muss
vergaß man sicher sind ja glaube ich
sowieso für die zu mindestens teilweise
lockerung der masken pflicht
würden sie das jetzt auch so
aufrechterhalten wenn uns die delta
variante tatsächlich droht ja es ging ja
darum wo ist masken pflicht wo es nicht
sinnvoller wo es laut aussage auch der
oso falsche eigentlich relativ sinnfrei
und an der frischen luft ist sie nicht
fürchterlich hilfreich als operateur das
ist der sinn von masken im
entsprechenden sitting ist mir durchaus
vertraut und wenn sie mit fremden
menschen auf engem raum wenn sie noch so
stehen das ist ein anderer macht das
durchaus sinn
draußen im biergarten ist es sicherlich
nicht hilft und ich glaube gar nicht
dass es bis herbst wird die date up wird
sehr viel schneller in die dominierende
variante werden das mag
verschiedene gründe aber ich glaube das
muss man sicher noch keine angst machen
also es ist so hendrix steckt mal so
schön gesagt wir müssen diese lockerung
jetzt nicht im voll sprint zurücklegen
sondern schritt für schritt und das was
ich eingangs sagte ist ist diese
richtung wenn wir ein fußballspiel
machen und 60.000 letzte fassenden
stadion und neben der 10.000 menschen
rein
die vernünftig eingeschlossen sich das
risiko sehr gering an wenn wir das
natürlich bis zum letzten platz füllen
dann ist das natürlich schon art
feldversuch insofern ist da kann man
schon als testspiel bezeichnen die
engländer der uefa das verkaufen weil
dann wird man sehr schnell sehen ob das
zu machen ausbrechen wird also es gibt
ja nicht an und aus sondern es sieht ja
ganz viel dazwischen und ich hatte ein
bisschen mehr zu so etwas mehr ratio und
etwas weniger aufgeregtheit wir haben
die impfung das ist eine andere variante
wir haben ist eine ganz andere situation
als vor einem jahr
und man muss einfach schauen was sich
entwickelt und wenn wir viele
infektionen haben und wenig kranke ist
das ja auch noch kein grund zur panik
wir müssen glaube ich hier eine etwas
etwas die engel wir dann etwas coolere
kulagins weise haben das heißt ja nicht
dass man leichtsinnig ist und alles über
bord wirft aber diese ständigen
schreckensszenario bringen uns auch
nicht weiter auch nicht glaube
persönlich die menschen sind wirklich
müde
ich stimme ich völlig überein man kann
dieser generation jetzt nicht noch ein
ruiniertes bildungs und soziales jahr zu
muten wir haben jetzt schon eine massive
zunahme an psychischen störungen bei
kindern und jugendlichen wir werden
massive bildungsrepublik sehen
ausbildungsmesse nicht begonnen und
nicht beendet werden das ist eine hoch
dramatische situation und deshalb gilt
ist natürlich auf jeden fall hier wieder
so etwas zu vermeiden und deshalb bin
ich auch jemand der sagt also lockt dann
wäre der offenbarungseid für uns dazu
darf es nicht kommen und ich glaube auch
dazu wird es nicht kommen muss es auch
nicht gut ich habe ja schon gesagt über
den teufel nicht an die wand malen
trotzdem alle fälle durch sprechen auch
das worst case szenario bot sich jetzt
nämlich nochmal auf die wirtschaft haben
vorhin schon etwas dazu gesagt haben sie
eine vorstellung was das für die
wirtschaft bedeuten würde wenn wir da
noch mal in allen lockt und kämen was
das für die arbeitsplätze für die
wirtschaftskraft thema digitalisierung
sprechen wir gleich noch an
was das bedeutet ist da gibt es eine
vorstellung was das
für einen einbruch geben wird wir würden
in vielen bereichen das gleiche
durchmachen wie vorher also alle
dienstleistungsbereiche die sozusagen
sehr auf kontakte ausgerichtet sind die
würden natürlich wieder komplett
herunterfahren müssen natürlich haben
wir jetzt instrumente die uns helfen
vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr zu
öffnen
wir haben umgekehrt gesehen dass der
zweite und dritte lockdown die
wirtschaft wesentlich weniger hart
getroffen hat als beim ersten mal die
industrie konnte weitgehend weiter
produzieren das hat enorm geholfen ich
glaube für die wirtschaft ist
tatsächlich gut und wenn wir zwei dinge
tun das hat auch mit dem zu tun was was
gerade gesagt worden ist wir müssen
glaube ich über über daten besser
verstehen was das risiko ist wir wissen
immer noch viel zu wenig erschreckend
wenig über das eigentliche
infektionsgeschehen das risiko ist
unbekannt da müssen wir glaube ich
besser werden über über die nutzung von
daten und das zweite was wir tun müssen
ist das risiko zu kontrollieren also wir
müssen auf jeden fall und das ist das
beste für die wirtschaft und für die
gesellschaft insgesamt wenn wir das
gefühl haben wir das gefühl haben
sondern wirklich dieses risiko
kontrollieren können und wir haben jetzt
ja mehr instrumente das ist ja das
schöne im vergleich zu dem was wir vor
einem jahr haben wir haben jetzt mehrere
instrumente und das müsste uns
eigentlich helfen die kontrolle darüber
stärker an uns zu reißen
dass aber gerade weil es psychologisch
und eben auch ökonomisch zu verheerend
sein kann wenn sich das wiederholt alles
dafür tun dass eben dieser lockdown
nicht mehr nötig ist und möglicherweise
werde ja die ja sozusagen die saat dafür
jetzt gerade gelegt absolut absolut und
das muss glaube ich auch die wirtschaft
erkennen dass das wichtig ist dass wir
jetzt nicht komplett wieder sozusagen
zurückfallen in das was wir hatten
sondern dass wir wege finden auszukommen
also das was sie sagt und damit damit
leben zu lernen so deshalb war im grunde
das hatte ich vorhin angedeutet diese
diese ewigen versprechen sie
wiederholten versprechen der politik
jetzt müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen
warten und dann ist es vorbei
das natürlich quatsch und das ist
natürlich auch mental ganz schwierig ein
solches krisenmanagement zu versprechen
irgendwann ist vorbei nicht wie ökonomen
sagen wir das ist zurzeit konsistenz
problem ich muss immer wieder
enttäuschungen produzieren weil ich
irgendwas der sprecher
was ich gar nicht versprechen kann also
wären besser zu signalisieren
das ist jetzt da und wir wir erzeugen
wege daraus so das ist glaube ich die
orientalen der server haltung gegenüber
dieser krise wir jetzt in der korona in
der korona epoche sozusagen seit dem
letzten frühjahr ja verschiedene
mutationen erlebt dass ich jetzt bei
delta das griechische alpha beta
dummerweise noch eine ganze reihe von
buchstaben so von aqaba variante als
nächstes jetzt die rede und geht dann in
dem alphabet immer weiter vor diese
mutationen werden die eigentlich immer
aggressiver werden die immer
unberechenbarer weil eben dass das virus
sich anpassen will und merkt wenn es
wenn es auf immunabwehr trifft dann
überlege ich mir jetzt was anderes liegt
da eine große gefahr die auch weiterhin
besteht oder kann man da auch durch
eigenes verhalten was dagegen machen
na ja es werden ja laufend neue
mutationen neue variationen entstehen
und die die halt besonders fit ist für
die jungen die sich besonders gut an die
umgebung anpassen kann
die setzt sich dann durch das ist jetzt
zum beispiel in england ist das ja nicht
ohne grund das da diese oder das oder in
indien das kleine variante auftritt die
sich besonders gut durchsetzen kann weil
sie sich wahnsinnig schnell verbreiten
kann das ist der große vorteil die im
varianten die in südafrika und brasilien
aufgetreten sind da sieht man schon dass
die dem immunsystem so ein bisschen
entweichen können also dass die
impfstoffe da nicht ganz so gut wirken
das wird natürlich sich immer weiter und
immer wieder neu entstehen der vorteil
ist nur als wir gucken jetzt immer nur
auf europa man darf ja nicht vergessen
ein großer teil der welt ist noch gar
nicht geimpft das ist natürlich noch mal
ganz bitter aber wenn in europa viele
menschen und die meisten menschen
geimpft sind dann gehen wir treten wir
diesen virus und auch den varianten
anders gegenüber
dann sind wir nicht mehr so schutzlos
wir jetzt jetzt sind wir quasi also
quasi nackt diesen virus gegenüber
getreten und dann haben wir ein bisschen
was an
dann kann vielleicht noch mal eine
variante kommen die auch wieder fies ist
aber dann muss man den impfstoff ein
bisschen anpassen das geht ja alles
diesem ehrenabend stoffe sind ja auch
flexibel da drin aber man ist nicht mehr
so absolut hilflos diesem virus
ausgeliefert wie gesagt ein großer teil
der welt hat noch lange nicht diesen im
status erreicht was wir uns war ja zu
lesen durch die immer aggressiveren
mutation und varianten des corona virus
müsste auch in deutschland die härten
immunität also der punkt an dem
sozusagen das virus unter kontrolle ist
weil genügend menschen geimpft sind der
müsste etwa bei 85 prozent der
bevölkerung legen und nicht bei 70 oder
bei 60 über das vielleicht vor einem
jahr gedacht hat aber diese 85 prozent
erreichen sie arithmetisch betrachtet
nicht in dem sie auch kinder impfen
ich glaube die erreichen wir sowieso
nicht also für macht's prozent im sport
habe ich noch nie von gehört weltweit
gibt es nirgendwo selbst wenn damit
impfen ich glaube ich werde dich
erreichen
die varianten werden ja auch alles über
klingt das so als wären sie auch viel
gefährlicher das ist ja eine ganz andere
betrachtungsweise zunächst wann werden
sie denn jetzt hier eher anstecken so
das ist das eine
ich glaube dass wir eine so hohe im
durch impfung nicht hinbekommen die
werden wir vielleicht auch nicht
brauchen
wir haben jetzt im moment offiziell
knapp vier millionen genesene wenn sie
immer nur eine dunkelziffer von faktor
zwei bis drei unterstellen kann man
wahrscheinlich von 10.000.000 genesen
und aus gehen das ist eher konservativ
geschätzt
mit den impfungen haben wir die
vielleicht dann sozusagen im nebengang
erreicht aber sie werden nicht von 80
prozent durch impfen können die impfung
bei den kindern und jugendlichen das
muss man einfach sehen ist insofern
nicht ganz unproblematisch weil wir
wissen kinder und jugendliche erkranken
selten schwer in der regel dann wenn sie
vorher krank sind
insofern spiegelt die stiko empfehlung
das auch gut wieder
wir sehen aber es gibt doch zum teil
nicht ganz banale nebenwirkung bei ihm
von gerade bei kindern und jugendlichen
bürokratie tieren werden berichtet also
herzmuskelentzündung
insofern glaube ich die risikoabwägung
ist hier im moment so dass ich gesunde
kinder nicht impfen lassen würde und ich
kann auch nicht nachvollziehen dass es
menschen gibt die das eigentlich
einfordern um ebendiese herr limonit zu
bekommen ich denke die erwachsenen
wohnbevölkerung muss wenn der infrarot
habe das für sich entscheiden ob sie das
annehmen will oder nicht eine
impfpflicht halte ich auch für nicht
angemessen
wer sich dann nicht impfen lässt das ist
auch ok muss mit einem höheren risiko
leben muss vielleicht dann auch in die
wieder schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen das ist
ja steht jedem frei
wir können natürlich aber nicht mehr
einfordern wenn es eine impfung
theoretisch für jeden gäbe und einige
nehmen die nicht wahr dass wir dann
seien gut weil man sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen müssen wir jetzt alle gott
dann warendorf masken truck etc
also ich glaube hier ist irgendwann dann
auch die informierte entscheidung sollen
wenn wir bei unseren patienten die ist
dann gefordert
da setzt natürlich voraus dass wir für
je nach umfang haben das ist natürlich
klar ich kann ja nicht sagen wir dass
jetzt alle alle vorsicht fahren es gibt
die hälfte künftiger ressort sehen wo er
bleibt aber wenn wir einfach angebot
wirklich für alle anbieten können
doch das ist der zeitpunkt wo man dann
wirklich sagen dann ist das einzel
verantwortung und die kinder und
jugendlichen sollte daraus sondern wir
sollten individuelle risiko bewerten und
vorher krank so sollen geimpft werden
und die anderen würde ich im moment lang
stand heute wohl eher nicht hier sieht
man das eben vereinigten königreich was
kinder und jugendlichen impfung angeht
verglichen mit deutschland ist das
vereinigte königreich ein crooner
hotspot findet diese diskussion da ein
ähnlicher weise statt um eben dass cora
virus gerade diese gefährliche delta
variante einzudämmen
da sind wir noch nicht also weil die
briten ja wirklich noch einen sehr
klaren schema geimpft haben also erst
risikogruppen und dann ganz ganz klar
nach alter altersgruppen wir sind jetzt
bei den über 18-jährigen angekommen und
die diskussion über über überall sie
gibt es sie gibt es durchaus weil man
sieht ja das beispiel usa
man orientiert sich hier ja auch immer
mal wieder gerne an den usa das also in
den usa wirklich kinder schon schon
geimpft werden und es gibt da auch
stimmen die da die danach rufen aber ich
bin jetzt nicht da in der lage schon ein
urteil abgeben zu können wo der hase
lang läuft hier was diese entscheidung
betrifft jetzt ist man erstmal wirklich
darauf konzentriert zu versuchen
erwachsene so weit zu impfen dass sie
von der delta variante nicht betroffen
werden und nicht ja sagen wir mal ins
also das ist ja der punkt dass die delta
variante bei doppelt geimpften fast
keine krankenhauseinweisungen verursacht
und wenn man das erreicht hat bei 18 bis
25 jährigen dann dann ist das große ziel
erreicht dann kann man auch weiter
lockern
jetzt haben wir ja bei der diskussion
und impfen für kinder und jugendliche
nicht nur vorgehalten gast und auch die
stiko die ständige impfkommission hat ja
davon abgeraten das nicht empfohlen
außer bei kindern mit vorerkrankungen
jetzt sollen aber dass ich auch gerade
eine wilde diskussion der öffentlichkeit
nach den ferien möglichst viele wenn ich
alle kinder in den präsenzunterricht
wenn die da aber alle nicht geimpft sind
ist die gefahr nicht groß dass sie sich
an alle gegenseitig anstecken und die
ganze impfkampagne auch zum teil
entwertet wird
ist sie das vergessen das ist jetzt die
verantwortung der erwachsenen also alle
für die der impfstoff einen größeren
nutzen als ein risiko bringt für kinder
kann man das eben noch nicht zeigen dass
es in der verantwortung der erwachsenen
dass sie dafür sorgen dass die kinder in
die präsenzunterricht können ohne
gefährdet zu sein schwer zu erkranken
weil wenn man hat in israel gesehen dass
wenn viele erwachsene geimpft sind dann
schützt das auch die kinder gerne über
die pandemien weggesehen die schulen
sind und auch die kita ist sind quasi
ein spiegel der gesellschaft habe ich
eine hohe inzidenz in der schule
außerhalb der schule dann habe ich auch
eine hohe inzidenz in der schule und
natürlich gibt es da auch fälle und das
wollen wir nicht weil auch wenn die
meisten kinder 519 gut überstehen manche
überstehen es nicht gut und longo wird
gibt es auch bei kindern
das heißt wir wollen das risiko
minimieren für die kinder deswegen
sollte sich jeder erwachsene gut
überlegen dass er sich impfen lässt und
die olympischen dörfer die imkerei naja
ich finde das wird ja mal sehr hoch
gehalten dass jeder das ganz frei
entscheiden kann aber es muss sich jeder
klar sein
er entscheidet nicht nur für sich
alleine ob er sich impfen lässt oder
nicht wenn ich sage ich lasse mich nicht
impfen dann erhöhe ich das risiko für
andere menschen für kinder
sich nicht impfen lassen können für alte
menschen bei denen der immunschutz
vielleicht nicht so gut ist weil er
einfach das hat man festgestellt dass
bei älteren doch das ein oder andere mal
der impfschutz nicht so gut ist wie bei
jüngeren menschen
das muss man sich klarmachen dass man
schon auch eine politische entscheidung
da trifft eine entscheidung die
auswirkungen auf die gesellschaft habe
ich sehe das auch wie herr gassen
irgendwann ist dann auch gut wenn jeder
sein angebot gehabt hat dann muss ich
auch nicht mehr schutzmaßnahmen
ergreifen da muss sich jeder um sich
selber kommen weil der dass sich nicht
impfen lässt er will eine konsequenz von
kobe 19 war unter anderem ein
aufkommendes phänomen das man bis dahin
noch nicht kannte das homeschooling dass
die kinder eben nicht mehr die schule
gehen konnten sondern monate lang zu
hause bleiben mussten jetzt war von den
psychischen familiären problemen die
dabei auch eine rolle spielen
es hat sich auch gezeigt dass wir ein
riesendefizit in sachen digitalisierung
im land haben das war keine heldentat
der deutschen geschichte dieser
erfahrung der letzten anderthalb jahre
lässt sich da tatsächlich in absehbarer
zeit etwas ändern digitalisierung in der
wirtschaft gehört ja auch zu ihrem
forschungsschwerpunkt was glauben sie
was ist da viel falsch gelaufen und vor
allen dingen wie lässt sich dieses von
allen beklagte dilemma beheben wir
müssen die defizite sind glaube ich mehr
als offenkundig geworden dass wir der
riesige rückstände haben und viele
glauben wir hätten jetzt digitalisierung
verstanden das ist nicht so nicht also
nur weil wir es virtuelle konferenzen
machen und ein bisschen home office
haben das ist nicht digitalisierung sind
weit weit weit entfernt von einer echten
digitalen gesellschaft wir haben keine
digitalen bildungsangebote von digitale
infrastruktur bis an die letzte
milchkanne will ich gar nicht gar nicht
reden aber das natürlich deutlich mehr
wie gehen wir mit daten um und so weiter
also ganz vieles ist da ist da zu tun
und wir müssen das haben wir glaube ich
erkannt wir haben in hunderten und
tausenden von unternehmen haben wir die
digital office gehabt und die wussten
und die haben gesagt wir brauchen
digitalisierung heute kann die halt
gezeigt zu was sie gut ist also sie
hilft uns dieses instrument wirklich
unser leben zu organisieren
und wir haben ja gesehen wenn das wenn
das wegbricht das was wir in
infrastruktur als gesellschaft aufgebaut
haben das wegbricht erzeugen wir
unglaubliche ungerechtigkeit
bildungsjahr und nur noch ganz wenig
zeit
was bedeutet das eigentlich welche
langzeitwirkungen hat dieses defizit in
bezug auf wirtschaftswachstum
ökonomische stabilität der gesellschaft
enorme also es ist die forschung dazu
die die zeit in den ersten fünf jahren
eines eines menschenlebens werden ganz
wesentliche grundlagen gelegt nicht
alles was danach kommt kann man sagen
ist quasi reparatur also diejenigen die
jetzt davon betroffen sind die werden
ihr leben lang womöglich das spüren so
und da müssen wir uns auch darum kümmern
ein weiteres argument dass sich die
krone varianten nicht weiter ausbreiten
ich bedanke mich bei andreas klassen war
ja sind herlein bei christina satori und
bei henning vögel liebe zuschauer die
nächste phoenix gesprächssendung die ist
am montag um 22 uhr 15 unter den linden
da bleiben wir beim thema corona und die
folgen gast ist unter anderem karl
lauterbach zu gast ist er bei eva
lindenau am montag um 22 uhr 15
jetzt verspricht der tag mit constanze
après ski darin unter anderem die
ergebnisse vom heutigen eu-gipfel
bleiben sie bei uns